we want to prove that a B and minus BD n
is divisible by a minus B for that
condition okay now I would usually just
launch straight into my test and then I
would see what happens from there okay
but there's actually something really
sneaky hiding in there we've been
thinking a lot about restrictions
haven't we invest trig and all that I
know this has nothing to do with the
industry but you start to realize that
restrictions sometimes they're kind of
invisible but they're still important
right now when you're talking about to
visibility you know you're automatically
thinking about positive numbers and
you're thinking about whole numbers
right a being that we're talking about
positive numbers right that implies a
restriction or rather a relationship
between a and B namely that if I'm
division why don't we don't really talk
about things mean to his will by like
negative two or something like that so
if this is gonna be a positive number of
some kind right if a minus B is going to
be positive
then a has to be greater than B okay so
this will become a part of the way that
I think later on as I go through this
okay let's test the first allowable case
which according to this is N equals one
that gives me a to the one minus B to
the one which I hope is divisible by a
minus B so that's good first case okay
so my assumption how shall I write it
out here's my case case okay and I'll
say it's equal to now they want it to
just be divisible by right so that's
this is some kind of no but this is not
X to the N right this is some number a
might be three or five or 23 or whatever
and some number B so therefore this will
be a minus B naught times a polynomial
there are no polynomials here this will
be just times some other number okay
such that K and P all follow the same
rules okay so now what am i required to
prove I've got a to the K plus 1 B to
the K + 1 and I'm still going to be a
minus B times something else some
on the number my curly braces are
getting progressively worse as you can
see all right now what I do with this
thing
well again I can see that the assumption
is hiding in here I just have to use my
index laws properly okay so I'll go left
hand side there are there's what it is
as written so if I use my NYX laws that
means I've got a lots of Advocate there
and I've got be lots of B to the K there
okay now in previous cases when you've
got numbers here right so for is this
suppose you saw this suppose you saw
three times n to the K minus two times B
to the K all right now in these kinds of
cases we've got no problem we say oh how
much of the assumption can I fit in
there and the answer is I could fit two
right so you'd say well okay I've got
1/8 of a case sitting at the front then
I've got two lots of a to the K and two
lots of B to the K and then you're like
okay there's where I started my
assumption now this is easier to fit
into our heads because of the numbers
right but the thing is a and B are also
just numbers we just don't know what
their values are I can still work with
them in exactly the same way okay so
remember I said that a is B gonna be
okay
so this would be the three and this
would be the two or whatever okay
whatever I know whatever I've got I know
that I've got more of these than I have
in these okay so therefore I want to
have be lots of a to the K and be lots
of B to the K okay now if I've taken out
be lots of these how many do I have left
over and the answer is well I had one
here right when the one come from came
from the three minus two right so I
should have a minus B lots because I
took out be lots of editor K there plus
all of this okay so that that's trickier
to do with pretty rules that it is with
numbers but it's exactly the same trick
that's why that's one okay so now and
you in some ways we should have expected
an a minus B because that's what we're
supposed to prove okay so I've got my a
minus B a to the K then I've got be lots
of my assumption or the left hand side
of most
should anyway okay so now I can use the
assumption a - be there be there and
what did I say it was equal to a minus B
times P by the assumption and you'd
write it out if you had more space and
now I can factorize a Busby I've got one
lot of them here and I've got B P lots
of them yeah okay and so that's equal to
because one and B and P they're all
positive integers okay
and so I can say that's a motifs B times
I'll call that Q and essentially I've
done I would have to conclude of course
but that's the that's the algebraic
legwork oh yeah of course
which would mean this should be an
indication yeah I think the main thing
was recognizing this so that you can do
that yeah yeah so I went from here to
here right so when I'm talking about
divisibility visibility that implies
you've got positives and you got whole
numbers okay so we're used to the whole
number business right but the positive
we don't tend to think about so
something like this doesn't come to you
immediately you have to think about it
and from that you can draw these kinds
of conclusions